Hi.
Welcome to New Body.
Thank you.
Can I help you?
Yeah, I just started
working out this morning,
so I need a little revamp
on my wardrobe
for the new body
I'm about to have.
Oh, my God, fabulous.
What's your fitness plan?
Well, I switched
to Diet Snapple
and I bought
a tiny house trampoline.
Mm-hmm.
So, you know, a change
a-gonna come.
What size are you now?
I'm a 4 at Old Navy.
Okay, so an 8.
Yeah.
And what size are you thinking
your new body's gonna be?
Uh, I'm definitely
gonna be a size 2.
Congratulations.
That's such a great size.
Thanks.
And is there any special
occasion you're preparing for?
Yeah, I've been catfishing
a guy in Michigan
and sending him
pictures of Kate Bosworth
and saying that they're me,
and we're supposed
to meet up in two weeks.
I love everything
about that plan.
Same.
Why don't we walk over
here to the "five months
from now" section?
Okay.
Come on.
Oh, my God,
I love this.
But it's a size 0.
That's a size smaller
than I was thinking
my new body would be.
But it's so cute.
Isn't it so cute?
Doesn't it make you
want to kill yourself?
Yes!
All right, listen to me.
If I were you, I would just
make my delusional diet
a little more unachievable.
Then it will
hang on you.
Okay, why not?
Why not?
Do you have a place where I can
sit and eat this muffin?
Oh, sure,
right over there.
How's it going in there?
Be honest.
Honestly, I love this
for future you.
You need to wear this
when all your lies
are exposed in Michigan.
That's what
I was thinking.
The best part about it
is it's so easy.
So easy.
Also, is there
a place I can sit
and eat this
other muffin?
It's my cheat day.
Oh, yeah, right where
you had the first one.
Thanks.
Amazing.
Um, this was
unrealistic.
No returns!